[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magacín informativo 100 dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre de
liliana valencia aquí damos una mirada
en profundidad a los hechos de
actualidad de la semana en la cuna de la
humanidad
en etiopía las fuerzas rebeldes se
tomaron la antigua localidad de lalibela
conocida por sus iglesias que son
patrimonio de la humanidad reconocidas
por la unesco alrededor de
250.000 personas resultaron desplazadas
del lugar sagrado agravando la crisis
política y social que se vive en esta
nación
la organización mundial de la salud
sostiene que el continente africano está
pasando por su pico más alto de muertes
ocasionadas por el cob y de 19 la mayor
parte de ellas son reportadas de túnez y
sudáfrica esto al tiempo que llegan más
vacunas al continente en un intento por
acelerar el ritmo de la vacunación
en este capítulo de áfrica siete días
hablamos con el escritor y líder social
usman mar nacido en ghana y radicado en
españa que recientemente publicó su
libro el país de los blancos donde
cuenta su historia de admiración el
texto le ha significado reconocimientos
y un importante premio nacional
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días hablando de
etiopía porque integrantes de las
fuerzas rebeldes de la región del tigre
se tomaron la localidad de lalibela una
antigua ciudadela conocida por sus
iglesias excavadas en la roca que fueron
declaradas patrimonio de la humanidad
por parte de la unesco desde el
estallido de los combates en noviembre
de 2020 entre el ejército y los
insurgentes el país africano y una
crisis política social y alimentaria que
ha dificultado también el ingreso de la
asistencia humanitaria
lalibela en el norte de etiopía es un
lugar único en el mundo alberga 11
iglesias monolíticas talladas
enteramente en roca y que datan de los
siglos 11 y 12 es un lugar sagrado para
millones de cristianos ortodoxos etíopes
[Aplausos]
pero el conflicto en la región de tigres
se extendió a jara región donde se
encuentra la nivel a las fuerzas
rebeldes de la región de tigre se
tomaron la ciudad antigua provocando el
desplazamiento de unos 250 mil personas
y generando temores por el futuro de la
también conocida como la segunda
jerusalén
hacemos un llamado de frente de
liberación popular de tigre para
proteger este patrimonio cultural y a
todas las partes del conflicto para
poner fin a la violencia
el conflicto en el norte de etiopía
estalló en noviembre de 2020 cuando el
gobierno central del país atacó al
frente de liberación popular de tigre
tras meses de intensos combates el
gobierno etíope declaró victoria luego
de haber retomado mekelle la capital de
tigre pero los soldados oficiales se
retiraron a finales de junio los
enfrentamientos han provocado una gran
crisis social y alimentaria
según un informe de la onu que data de
junio 55 millones de habitantes de tigre
están bajo condición de inseguridad
alimenticia de las cuales 2 millones
están bajo un nivel de emergencia grave
en noticias del coi 19 el continente
africano y de su momento más crítico
desde el inicio de la pandemia la
organización mundial de la salud
confirmó que las muertes relacionadas
con el virus marcaron un récord inédito
entre finales de julio y principios de
agosto con más de 6.400 muertes un
aumento del 2 por ciento con respecto a
semanas anteriores
países como sudáfrica y túnez los más
afectados del continente reportan más
del 55 por ciento de los decesos sin
embargo estas muertes están aumentan
también en otros 15 países el incremento
de los contagios en el continente tiene
que ver con la variante delta y con la
lentitud de las campañas de vacunación
sin embargo la delegada de la
organización mundial de la salud para la
vacunación en áfrica dijo que están
llegando más vacunas al continente
después de tres duros meses
áfrica instead on the christ of stars
wave áfrica todavía está en la cima de
la tercera ola y aún registra más casos
que en cualquier pico anterior no
podemos dar nada por hecho y debemos
mantenernos plenamente comprometidos con
las medidas de prevención
lamentablemente las muertes en áfrica
alcanzaron un pico récord esta semana y
con más de 6.400 muertes registradas es
récord y este continente africano es uno
de los más rezagados en materia de
vacunación y también se registran
profundas desigualdades entre sus
diferentes naciones veamos en el
siguiente gráfico los países con más
dosis aplicadas son en primer lugar está
marruecos con más de 25 millones 965 mil
vacunas inoculadas después en segundo
lugar se encuentra sudáfrica con 8
millones 621 mil 900 dos dosis aplicadas
y en tercer lugar encontramos a egipto
con cinco millones 649 mil 322 vacunas
en contraste los países con menos dosis
aplicadas son tanzania que apenas está
aplicando sus primeras dosis y no
reporta cifras oficiales y me avisó con
25 mil 225 y también encontramos a chad
con 36 mil 173 dosis inoculadas
cambiamos de información y vamos a mali
porque al menos 51 personas murieron
tras un ataque perpetrado por presuntos
militantes islamistas en tres aldeas
cercanas a la frontera con níger el
ataque ocurrió en el norte del país
cuando presuntos insurgentes habrían
asesinado a un grupo de agricultores que
volvían del campo al tiempo que
asesinaron a dos ciudadanos e
incendiaron tiendas en las aldeas el
norte de mali vi una espiral de
violencia en las últimas décadas con
ataques de grupos yihadistas locales
contra civiles el ejército del país o
los efectivos de la misión de la onu
pasamos a temas de migración porque la
trata de personas afecta a miles de
ciudadanos en el continente africano una
de las fronteras de más se presenta esta
problemática es la de las ciudades
españolas de ceuta y melilla con
marruecos desde marrakech nos amplía
nuestra corresponsal sofía catalán
trata de personas se puede definir como
el comercio ilegal y la
instrumentalización violenta de seres
humanos en situación de vulnerabilidad
para fines de explotación es una lacra
que afecta a millones de personas en el
mundo y según los datos de las naciones
unidas- tres cuartas partes del total de
víctimas son mujeres y dentro de la
complejidad de las redes de trata se
distingue claramente que la mayoría de
víctimas proceden del sur global y son
explotadas en países del norte y países
de tránsito y es que la trata de
personas está estrechamente vinculada a
los procesos migratorios irregulares y a
la limitación del derecho a la movilidad
de las personas en la mayoría de casos
las víctimas de trata no han tenido
acceso a vías legales y seguras para
llegar a su destino que suelen ser
lugares con un régimen de fronteras muy
restringido como es el caso de eeuu o de
la unión europea y aquí en la región del
magreb y concretamente en marruecos la
mayoría de víctimas de trata son
efectivamente las personas migrantes
procedentes en este caso de áfrica
sub-sahariana que se ven abocadas a la
mendicidad forzada y sometidas a redes
de explotación sexual y laboral en su
tránsito migratorio hacia europa
y justamente hablamos de migración pero
también de literatura porque en áfrica
siete días hablamos con el escritor y
líder social nació en ghana osman omar
quien se ha convertido en una figura la
lucha por los derechos de los migrantes
africanos desde barcelona sus manos con
todo parte de su historia y los orígenes
de su libro el país de los blancos
mi nombre es osman una nací en ghana a
los 9 años la curiosidad me empujó a
marchar de mi casa natal aprenden
chapistería a la ciudad y posteriormente
a los 12 13 años en marque un viaje
infernal recordar todo lo que es el
camino de la migración a través del
título del norte de áfrica donde más de
90 concesión de mis compañeros con
quienes invitó el viaje aprendieron la
vida en el recorrido decirlo es fácil
vivir otra cosa pues tanto su labor
social como su libro le ha significado a
sumar un mar el reconocimiento a nivel
nacional e internacional
recientemente recibirte bien princesa de
girona por su esfuerzo a favor de los
migrantes y de la juventud africana y
sintió orgulloso del reconocimiento que
me acaban de otorgar el premio princesa
elegir una especialmente en el centro
social del año 2021
es verdad que hace casi 10 años desde
que llegué a españa vi clarísimo que la
solución de la inmigración no está al
mar sino que está en el origen del
problema y mi propósito debería llegar
con vida no había sido por ser el más
fuerte ni el más inteligente sino que
había llegado para cumplir mi propósito
de vida dado por los compañeros que no
llegaron con vida y trabajar en la
región del problema para evitar que
futuras víctimas caigan en esa trampa
infernal mediante que la ong más cofidis
mainz alimentarnos mentes mediante la
educación digital damos formación
informacional y seis jóvenes en sus
casas para que puedan tener un futuro
mejor
continuamos con tema de la días fuera
porque se realizó en nueva york un
festival de comida criolla liderada por
africanos radicados en la gran manzana
por medio de la gastronomía estos
cocineros de alta calidad quisieron
demostrar la relación entre eeuu áfrica
y el caribe que se expresa a través de
los sabores díaz públicos de la región
[Aplausos]
así ha recibido nueva york la tercera
edición del festival de comida criolla
con música y muy buen ritmo
y para que las fuerzas no flaquean los
asistentes han podido disfrutar de
creaciones únicas en la cocina criolla
un estilo gastronómico que combina
influencias francesas españolas
occidentales y del norte de áfrica
además de haitianas y portuguesas
este es una conexión que ya existía
porque las tradiciones que vienen de
áfrica occidental junto con las de los
indígenas taínos que vivían en el caribe
terminan uniendo a eeuu con todas estas
regiones asignación a lengua triola y
toda una cultura criolla que representa
esa unión reflejada en la comida de las
juergas
este festival al que han asistido más de
500 personas pretende unir las culturas
en el momento en el que el mundo tiende
a dividir las aquí cada gastronomía
tiene su espacio y al mismo tiempo la
influencia de quienes la rodean los
lobos uap hipo
y todos nosotros somos personas cercanas
al agua todos venimos de la costa y
tenemos la misma cultura caribeña
incluso los españoles comen como
nosotros les gusta el picante el pescado
los camarones
odiada toda la gente del caribe tenemos
el mismo gusto
así nos lo cuenta la máxima
representación en gastronomía africana
la chef eugene bongo nacida en camerún y
asentada en maryland dirige un catering
de comida africana que hoy ofrece a los
neoyorquinos que asisten a este festival
ella y su trabajo son los mejores
embajadores de su pierna tal y es que no
es fácil encontrar auténtica comida
africana en la gran manzana muchos de
sus ingredientes básicos no son fáciles
de encontrar
haciendo boyas amantes
los picantes son muy diferentes incluso
tenemos salsas que fueron preparadas con
picantes naturales traídos de camerún
fue así como las hicimos también
podríamos encontrarlos en sudamérica y
américa central pero si queremos tener
el sabor original tenemos que traerlos
de áfrica algunos de nuestros bocadillos
tienen madera de los árboles lo que
hacemos es tomar la madera tostada y
rallar la para mezclarla con la salsa
así de específica son nuestras recetas
pues efe queréis
sensaciones únicas para el paladar que
en los próximos meses podrán disfrutar
en miami nueva orleans y washington y
todo para mostrar a eeuu una tradición
histórica que tiene su origen en la
época colonial y nos acerca sabores de
diversidad cultural
y finalizamos con música de la cantante
congoleñas ara calume quien
recientemente presentó su canción on you
con un vídeo que es sencillo pero lleno
de contenido la queens y como se le
conoce en todo el continente le da los
primeros lugares de las listas de
reproducción y de las emisoras de su
país así finalizamos este capítulo de
áfrica siete días pero ustedes pueden
continuar con más en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom vemos más adelante con
más información quédense con nosotros
[Música]
solo
no sé tampoco
m
[Música]
su camino